demain et toute cette semaine dans les
éditions de 13h et 20h sur antenne 2
suite de cette enquête sur l'urss de
gorbatchev
mais l'urss de gorbatchev c'est aussi la
présence maintenue de troupes
soviétiques en afghanistan ce soir grâce
à médecins sans frontières qui célèbre
ses 15 années d'action humanitaire des
images nouvelles d'afghanistan rony
brauman est à mes côtés
on le verra tout à l'heure il est
président de msf revient d'afghanistan
voici ce qu'il a pu voir les premières
images sont presque jolie celles qui
suivent sont dramatiques commentaires
patrice pollet au coeur de l'afghanistan
rony brauman ici au centre
motif de la visite du patron de médecins
sans frontières établir un nouveau camp
s'assurer que l'équipe de msf pourra
rester et travailler en sécurité pour
parvenir à un accord il faudra plusieurs
jours de discussions leurs
interlocuteurs les résistants afghans et
leur chef koré abdullah il commande la
région de race la région
s'étant déjà les médecins sans
frontières sont présents en afghanistan
depuis le début ces temps de travail
dans des conditions éprouvantes
ce village a été bombardée par
l'artillerie soviétique
on opère un blessé à la lumière d'une
simple lampe deux éclats d'obus dans le
dos de cette petite fille deux éclats en
pleine colonne vertébrale les médecins
apprendront à la mer que sa fille est
paralysé à vie ce petit garçon bois pour
la dernière fois il a deux ans son corps
est criblée d'éclats d'obus
trois morts dont sept enfants plusieurs
blessés graves le bilan de la taxe
soviétique
les médecins sans frontières sont restés
cinq heures sur place
et puis ils sont repartis anonyme
bénévole ils s'abstiennent de toute
critique à l'égard des pays qui
acceptent leur présence sous tous les
régimes
partout ils sont tous ceux qui souffrent
peuvent compter sur eux